what's going on guys welcome back to
geek culture explained my name is rob
and in this video i'm going to reveal to
you guys how it is
that i know what's going on over the
course of the loki show
and who the main villain of the show is
by breaking down key points
over the course of the first episode so
three things that i want to answer
before we get into this the first one
and probably the biggest question you
guys have is
why don't the infinity stones work when
they're in the offices of the tva so the
tva
exists in what's called null space which
is basically a place outside the
multiverse but even if that wasn't the
case if they existed in just some
alternate universe unto themselves
the infinity stones still wouldn't work
because the infinity stones only work in
their native universe because they're
powered
by that particular universe the second
thing that i want to answer is mephisto
in loki no the director of the tv show
came out and said that's not the case
even though we got the scene when owen
wilson's character asked the little kid
in the church who did this and a little
kid
points to what's basically a stained
glass version of the devil on the window
the answer of the director is that's a
reference to loki being cast out of
heaven
having horns on his head that kind of
thing so it's not really mephisto who's
going to appear in loki it would be cool
if they did and it's entirely possible
the director's just lying her ass off
but as far as we're aware that's not the
case and that's actually a good thing
because i think the variant version of
loki that we're getting in the show
is infinitely more interesting than
mephisto himself
the third thing that i want to answer
and it's really not even an answer so
much as just an easter egg that i
noticed i noticed a lot of them but
these are the ones that i thought were
the most interesting the scene when loki
first goes to the tva and he asked the
question what if i'm a robot and i don't
know
that's a reference to doombots doombots
are basically robot duplicates of dr
doom that he created to operate in his
stead when he doesn't want to appear in
public the reason why this is important
is because the doombots actually believe
they're dr doom they don't know their
robots so whenever it is the doombots
attack a city or something like that
it's usually only one that ever does it
then the doombot
operates as if they're dr doom it's a
really cool concept
the other reference could simply be to
life model decoys because life model
decoys don't know that they're decoys
they actually believe they're that
particular person and for the fourth
little easter egg that i found i
initially thought the little kid that
owen wilson's character was talking to
was bennett du perry it's not benidoo
perry was born a couple hundred years
before this kid but who has been a
duponte this guy
is a universally powerful telepath and
telekinetic he's also a mutant
yes i will take every chance i can to
speculate on the idea that whatever it
is that i happen to see in the mcu
is somehow going to bring mutants into
the mcu i'm sorry
i'm an x-men fan i will always do that
so having said all that let's talk about
this main villain of the series if i'm
being honest i think this variant
version of loki
is actually a character called ikol yes
it's loki spelled backwards nobody ever
said marvel was imaginative when it came
to names but here's the important thing
when it comes to this with loki's deaths
and resurrections they've happened a lot
over the years the classic version of
loki which is the version with horns and
all that kind of stuff he existed for
years and years and years until you got
to an event that was called
ragnarok you guys have all heard of this
it's also called thor disassembled in
the comics basically over the course of
this loki leaves an attack on asgard
thor is ultimately defeated and he ends
up going on this kind of crazy quest
this leads to him destroying the world
tree by destroying the world tree it
also destroys all the asgardians and
asgard itself
eventually a guy by the name of j
michael cerzinski started writing the
thor comics and when he did he had thor
rebuild asgard and brock's in oklahoma
and then basically started resurrecting
all the asgardians this happened because
the asgardian spirits lived on but they
were placed inside mortal bodies
eventually what happened is that he came
across the body that was supposed to
belong to seth but loki
actually took it and so loki comes back
as a woman now following that you go
into the lady loki storyline which
doesn't last super long and you get this
really really cool story where he
actually impersonates the scarlet witch
but the whole idea of lady loki
eventually goes into a story called
siege on asgard there's a lot of things
that go on none of which you guys really
care about
the important thing is that lady loki or
at least male loki who have been lady
loki at one point
ends up dying this gives birth to a
character named kid loki but then it
also goes into another version named
ikel while kid loki did come after the
events of siege honestly ikol is this
kind of
reincarnated version or the most modern
version of loki but aikol did some
pretty twisted stuff
initially he was just kind of a guy who
was trying to understand why he
sacrificed his life during the events of
siege but
far into the future he's a version of
loki that actually killed all the
superheroes on earth
really killed everybody on earth he
eventually became the all butcher after
taking the sword that belonged to gore
the god butcher who'd used it to kill
all kinds of gods from across the
universe but the question that has to be
asked here is if it really is that
future version of loki the character of
ikol
why is he traveling across the entirety
of the multiverse killing all these
different members of the time variance
authority and stealing their timeline
reset charges
if i'm a vetting man i think there's
only one of two possibilities here the
first
is that this version of ikol is working
for king the conqueror king the
conqueror as we know is going to appear
in ant-man 3. yes i know kevin feige
said the tv shows are not going to be
required viewing in order to understand
what's going on in the movies
but you guys are taking that too
literally it's like comic books yeah
sure there's a main event which is
basically the movies but then there's
also tie-ins are they required to
understand the main story
no do they help yes now if he really is
working for kane the conqueror i don't
think those two things will be connected
until we get to ant-man 3 and we
actually see jonathan majors as kane the
conqueror and if anything i think it'll
just bolster or at least go to show how
wide reaching the influence of king the
conqueror is after all
he rules entire sections of the
multiverse the second idea and the one
that's probably the most probable here
is that that version of loki
is a time twister so the tv show
established the idea that the tva was
created by the time keepers who exist to
basically make sure
that the timeline is maintained the
animation told us the time keepers came
together as a result of the chaotic mess
that was the war that initially started
that led to the entire madness that was
the multiverse at that particular point
in time in order to keep that from
happening the timekeepers condensed the
entire multiverse down to a singular
timeline in order to ensure that when
new alternate realities were created
that it was a controlled process
they couldn't just be done arbitrarily
the time twisters were the first attempt
to create
timekeepers it ended up going awry now i
don't know if it's like it is in the
comics where you have three time
twisters and then you have three time
keepers but i would argue that if this
is the case then that is a time twister
and the idea here is to
set the entire multiverse into madness
or the very least reset the entire
multiverse because we know whoever this
villain is is traveling around killing
off all these different members of the
tva who are investigating divergent
timelines that this person's basically
creating
and then as soon as the tva shows up
they're ambushed they're killed
and then their reset charger is taken
and if you combine enough of those
together it's akin to what gore the
godbutcher was doing in the jason aaron
thor god of thunder story where he was
looking to create a god bomb that he
would send throughout the entire time
stream
and basically kill all the gods across
the entirety of the universe
except imagine that it would just reset
the entirety of the multiverse just like
creating a giant reset button
that's what i think is most likely going
on here but let me know what you guys
think down in the comments section thank
you guys for watching
and i will catch you all later peace